there it is sixth round compensatory
selection
2 000 draft
tom brady
quarterback michigan
pick number 199
and as tom brady pointed out his nfl
career is now old enough to buy a beer
21 years
he has been in the national football
league there are guys in the league now
younger than his career there are guys
that are young enough to be his kid
there are guys that are less than half
his age
miles and he just
keeps going unbelievable career
unbelievable longevity achievement
performance everything
greatest player it's ever played i
remember there was a time not that long
ago where it was kind of loosely
regarded that jerry rice was the
greatest player of all time at any
position
that that ship has sailed with the super
bowl 51 win brady became the best
quarterback of all time and throwing two
more on top of that i don't think
there's any debate greatest player of
all time regardless of position
nah he's the goat it was cemented for me
with this one and because i just did not
see the buccaneers being
a winning team that could you know go to
the playoffs let alone a team that would
get to the super bowl and then dominate
and win the super bowl and look brady is
playing like a top five quarterback he's
now getting into his mid 40s it's
unbelievable what he's done and what he
continues to do and there's no reason to
believe that he's not going to keep
playing at that level at this point
yep and uh the question is how much
longer will he go there was a point
during the season last year where i
thought
this guy's going to play until he's 50.
45
just i mean
look why why would you stop if you can
still play especially because his family
seems to be very happy in tampa i think
it's a different vibe than new england
and i think he was beaten down by bill
belichick and
and it just it was time
now that they're in tampa they're happy
he's in a groove he knows what needs to
be done
and
for all quarterbacks i'd say at some
point if you're good and you're smart
you get into your 30s
you you become part player part coach
and your brain becomes that super
computer that has processed everything
after they beat the falcons in super
bowl 51 he said there's nothing that you
can show me that i haven't seen before
well he's got four more years of
football since then
so if he can physically keep doing it
and he's mastered also the ability to
basically duck and cover when he sees
someone coming at him who can inflict
physical damage on his aging body he
gets rid of the football and he and he
curls up and that's okay live to play
another day smart stay alive for your
team other teams wish their quarterbacks
were done 49ers if jimmy garoppolo would
have done it in 2018 he wouldn't have
torn his acl on the sideline week three
in kansas city so i'm impressed with
everything tom brady's done and uh
i want to see who the next guy is
to stretch his longevity as far as tom
brady has because i have a feeling he's
not going to be the only one to do it in
this generation of quarterbacks i think
there's going to be others
he's i mean this is not still his
generation of quarterbacks at this point
man i i mean he's his generation of
quarterbacks are they're all gone you
know pretty much the current generation
yeah russell wilson russell wilson says
he's going to play toys 45 and these
younger guys who are coming up now
there's so many good ones will one of
them make it deep into his 40s i think
one of them will
yeah i mean that makes a lot of sense
especially given the way the rules have
changed i mean even since tom brady's
been in the league right the rules have
changed so that you can't hit
quarterbacks low and you know you're not
supposed to do this with the quarterback
that with the quest so look i think that
yes you're right that the longer guys
play or the more time goes on i guess i
should say the guys are going to keep
playing a long time especially at the qb
position where the rules are basically
uh formed so that they can continue to
play at a high level
all right let's get to the draft the
biggest steals in nfl history draft
style the tom brady memorial draft
although he's still alive miles you get
the first pick well it can't be tom
brady because it's the tom brady
memorial draft and everybody knows that
he is obviously the biggest draft steal
of all time but i will go with somebody
else from califor who played in
california and that is joe montana and
he was selected in the third round in
1979 he got a four-time super bowl
champion three-time super bowl mvp and
he is the person who i thought tom brady
was going to start resembling you know
after he finished his 49ers career of
course joe montana went to kansas city
went to the playoffs thought that maybe
brady could get to the playoffs but then
brady wins the super bowl so but joe
montana i mean you're getting a guy like
that in the third round that's that's a
huge steal
i will go with another quarterback from
a generation before
montana and that would be a guy who was
drafted in the 10th round of the 1964
draft by the dallas cowboys roger
staubach had to fulfill his naval
commitment landed in the nfl and ended
up being one of the great quarterbacks
of his era one of the guys who never
really gets brought up in the
conversation for the all-time greats
shireen williams who has roger
staubach's jersey hanging behind her
whenever she's on the show she would
argue that he should be in that
conversation when she was in i think
third grade she asked her teacher how
far it is from houston to dallas she
grew up in the houston area and the
teacher said why she said i've got to go
i'm going to marry roger staubach so uh
and is this really you know i i i
wouldn't have included him
if i'd have known that we were going to
show the all-time cheat play by him and
drew pearson i bet he told drew pearson
before the snap if all else fails push
that guy down anyway i still i still say
starbucks one of the all-time great
drafts deals he also was drafted in the
16th round by the chiefs in the 1964 afl
draft miles
well that's good to know um very
interesting stuff there good trivia for
that uh but yeah shout out to shereen
williams who i was going to say roger
staubach with my next pick if you didn't
so we would have seen that clip anyway
mike um i will say my for my next pick
though is a steal deacon jones who was
taking the 14th round of the 1961 drive
talking about a guy who's two-time
defensive player of the year if i'm not
mistaken because this probably this not
probably this happened long before i was
born he coined the term sack right
because he's the one who was always
getting after the qb's and of course
back then there was no sac stat but if
there were he would have had 20 sacks
for three times in his career and that
is just unbelievable so i think he's
definitely one of the top drafts deals
of all time of the fearsome foursome in
l.a
he was also the master of the head slap
a move that became illegal but one of
the techniques for getting past an
offensive lineman was literally take
your palm and slap the offensive lineman
in the helmet rendering him momentarily
incapacitated apparently but that's what
deacon jones did to get to the
quarterback all right i'll go with
another quarterback here uh hall of
famer super bowl mvp twice
in that chain of great packers
quarterbacks although it was broken for
about i don't know 25 years it's been
solid for the last 25 from brett favre
to aaron rodgers it was bart starr
before that he was a 17th round draft
pick 17th round goes on to be one of the
great players in packers history and the
mvp of not just the first super bowl
before it was even called the super bowl
it was the afl nfl championship game but
also i don't i think they didn't even
come up with super bowl they may not
have come up with super bowl until three
i'm not sure yeah at some point lamar
hunt came up with the name but
regardless what is now in hindsight the
first two super bowls bart star was the
mvp
yeah i believe it was there was just the
football world championship or something
like that between the afl and the nfl in
those first two years uh great pick
though bart starr um but i am gonna go
sort of off the board here for my next
pick as a draft steal and i'm stretching
the rules because that's something you
always do whenever we do this mike but i
i i know what you're gonna i i know what
you're gonna do
oh okay go ahead no that's not what i
thought that's fine i know you're not
gonna want to deal with an undrafted guy
i thought you were going on a draft
again i thought you're gonna go kurt
warner because you can't you can't quit
the rams even though you quit the rams
four years ago you can't quit the rams
it's actually like two and a half or one
and a half bucks okay uh yeah
whatever it is yeah you're exactly and
you don't know how old i am anyway or
when my birthday is uh but the broncos
when they got john elway they traded for
they traded for him from the colts the
colts picked him at number one overall
but you're talking about a draft steal
how about a guy who becomes your
franchise quarterback for the better
part of two decades ends up winning two
super bowls for you late in his career
to finish off his career and they went
to enough super bowls and beat the team
with the helmet behind me in the 80s
many times in the playoffs so
i think that that is a kind of steal
because
look all the broncos had to give up was
the 19th overall pick the next year that
turned out to be ron
salt uh and then they gave up lime and
chris hinton and a backup quarterback in
mark herrmann that sounds like a draft
steal to me mike yeah no absolutely and
i have no problem with you doing it i
really did think you were going to go
with an undrafted guy because because
technically that's a draft steal that's
a guy who wasn't even picked i mean john
randle for crying out loud was undrafted
at a time when there were 12 rounds in
the draft he was undrafted all right i'm
gonna go with
there are other guys who had much better
careers like a steve smith who was a
third round pick in 2001 of the pants it
was like a shannon sharp who was a
seventh rounder uh of uh originally the
broncos and then went on to future
stardom further stardom excuse me with
the ravens i i'm gonna go to bo jackson
because i continue to be fascinated by
the bo jackson draft experience 1986
ready to play baseball buccaneers are
going to take him he told them
i'm not signing with you
i'm not doing it i'm going to play
baseball they use the first overall pick
on him anyway and the way the rules work
if you don't sign you go back into the
pool the next year and the raiders at a
time when no one else was really
thinking about it they threw i think it
was a seventh round pick on bo jackson
and i know his career didn't last very
long and i know that he had that hip
injury that that derailed both his
football baseball career and it's a
shame because the guy was magical the
guy was special it was fun to watch
baseball when he played it was even more
fun to watch football when he played but
for that that period that he burned he
burned as bright as anyone and to think
that the raiders got him for that steal
that the true steal you want to talk
about a steal nobody's even paying
attention to bo jackson oh here we go
thank you very much we'll take bo
jackson so literally a steal that's my
pick by the way the super bowl name
began to be used in super bowl four it
was the afl nfl championship game before
that but it was super bowl four when
lamar hunt's
brainstorm became the official name of
the game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports